this is the first time that humans are
not being chased into higher and higher
levels of work we're being chased out of
repetitive work whether it's high level
repetitive work the way that a
neurosurgeon might perform or low-level
repetitive work so your model of
Economics just
broke now when your water breaks when
your wife's water breaks it doesn't mean
that the baby is born instantly when the
contractions are coming 15 minutes apart
it's not yet time to be born this is the
moment
why are we not holding a conference on
after capitalism and communism what is
the next economic system do you imagine
that Adam Smith and Carl Marx would just
be sitting on their hands no they'd be
smart enough to say okay we now need a
new model it is bizarre that we are
sitting here inert saying gosh this is
going to break capitalism well no
kidding this is going to break
capitalism it's entirely clear that it's
going to break
capitalism